bonsoir
bonjour merci d'être avec nous monsieur
mclem gouverneur de la Banque du Canada
pour parler de votre décision et de
l'état de la situation présentement au
Canada est-ce qu'on comprend
à la lumière de ce que vous avez dit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut encore monter les
taux d'intérêt pour faire baisser
l'inflation même si ça peut provoquer
une récession au Canada
je pense que qu'est-ce que je veux dire
c'est que aujourd'hui on nous avons
relevé notre taux du directeur de 50
points de base et oui on est indiqué que
probablement il faut encore des hausses
de taux d'intérêt nous avons on voit
déjà les effets de les augmentations
taux d'intérêt que nous avons déjà fait
nous on voit les effets sur l'économie
et nous avons réduire notre prévision
pour le croissance on pense que pour le
3 prochaines trimestres croissance va
environ 0 et ça va diminuer les
pressions sur l'inflation
malheureusement c'est ont besoin de
moins de dépenses pour réduire ses
pressions mais trois prochains
trimestres à zéro est-ce que c'est une
récession dans votre esprit
avec
à peu près trois trimestres près de zéro
on peut avoir quelques trimestres
négatives on peut avoir quelques
trimestres avec un petit positif temps
c'est une ralentissement significatif de
l'économie c'est pas un contraction
majeur et ce n'est pas une récession
parce que je vous entends pas prononcer
le mot récession
dans votre idée dans votre scénario il
n'y a pas de récession
c'est pas récession majeure
c'est pas une récession majeure s'il y a
récession ce ne sera pas majeur
dites-vous
c'est ça c'est ça parfait vous avez
monté rapidement les taux d'intérêt sur
le dit au cours des prochains mois au
cours des derniers mois
cela dit l'inflation baisse légèrement
on commence à voir l'inflation BC est-ce
que votre politique que certains jugent
quand même agressive est-ce que vous
trouvez que votre politique fonctionne
si on regarde l'inflation oui
l'inflation les PC total a diminué de
8,1 à 6,9 dans les trois mois récents
mais cela reflète en grand parti le
réduction de prix de l'essence que on
voit tout le monde c'est bienvenu mais
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on quand on
regarde l'inflation c'est encore élevé
et c'est généraliser donc on n'a pas
encore vu des grands effets des hausses
tutos d'intérêt sur l'inflation mais on
commence à voir les effets sur
l'économie le marché de logements par
exemple les grands achats on voit que
les taux d'intérêt commence à réduire
l'activité et cela va réduire les
pressions à la hausse sur l'inflation et
donc j'espère que bientôt on commence à
avoir une réduction de taux d'inflation
mais nous sommes loin de notre cible de
2% et et ça dépend aussi de
l'approvisionnement des enjeux d'offres
en ce moment comment on va régler ça les
problèmes d'approvisionnement comment
vous voyez ça
l'évolution de situation internationale
c'est oui comme vous venez de mentionner
les
perdusations des chaînes
d'approvisionnement commencent à se
résulte résulu c'est c'est bon on espère
que ça continue le prix de pétrole
a diminué mais on peut pas compter sur
les enjeux international pour diminuer
l'inflation ici au Canada
l'inflation au Canada de plus en plus
reflète qu'est-ce qui se passe ici au
Canada et vraiment c'est à nous de
contrôler l'inflation domestique
l'ancien gouverneur de la Banque
d'Angleterre Marvin King dit récemment
qui a un risque actuel de crise
financière graves et que les banques
centrales sont en grande partie
responsable de la grave situation dans
laquelle se trouve en ce moment
l'économie mondiale qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous
nous avons vu des stress en quelques
marchés financières par exemple en
Angleterre plus récemment
ça reflète des conditions assez
spécifiques et en grand partie
l'ajustement des conditions financières
avec les forces des taux d'intérêts des
banques centrales c'est ajuster de
manière
raisonnablement normal donc oui il y
avait les risques c'est important que
les banques centrales les suites de prêt
et ils sont précis quelque chose arrive
mais à ce moment-ci l'ajustement c'est
c'est assez normal est-ce que vous vous
sentez vous responsable à la Banque du
Canada de la situation préoccupante
quand même dans laquelle nous sommes
présentement
nous sommes très conscients que nous
avons un mandat pour restaurer la
stabilité des prix et
c'est il n'y a pas une manière facile à
restaurer les prix malheureusement il
faut ralentir l'économie on comprend que
ça serait difficile pour plus plusieurs
Canadiens mais après une ralentissement
de croissance va revenir on va avoir du
Croissant solide avec un taux
d'inflation bas et prévisible mais
est-ce que vous devez est-ce que vous
devez monter les taux un peu plus haut
que souhaité monsieur maclem parce que
dans le fond vous avez tardé à faire
grimper les taux d'intérêt
nous avons augmenté notre taux d'intérêt
de manière rapide et il y a vraiment
deux raisons pour ça
on veut maintenir les anticipations
d'inflation bien ancrées et on va
réduire l'inflation et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit à ce moment c'est ça commence à
marcher ça commence à avoir des effets
sur l'économie réelle et comme j'ai
mentionné on anticipe que l'inflation va
diminuer dans notre prévision ce sera
environ 3% vers la fin de l'année
prochaine il y en a quand même qui vous
ont reproché monsieur maclem et à la
Banque du Canada d'avoir agi trop tard
comment on n'est pas comment vous êtes
certain aujourd'hui que vous n'allez pas
arrêter trop tard de monter les taux
d'intérêt
il y a les risques les deux côtés oui
ça se peut que comme j'ai mentionné les
enjeux et internationales peut
mettre plus de pression à la hausse sur
l'inflation ça peut que c'est plus
difficile qu'on pense à réduire
l'inflation mais à l'autre côté
l'économie peut être plus faible que on
a anticipant il y a des risques les deux
côtés on pense que notre prévision pour
l'inflation et assez sont assez bien
équilibrés
vis-à-vis cette prévisions mais avec
l'inflation beaucoup en haut de notre
cible nous sommes crus plus préoccupés
plus préoccupé par les risques à la
hausse je vais vous parler du mandat de
la Banque du Canada Monsieur le
Gouverneur l'objectif principal vraiment
de la banque c'est de maintenir
l'inflation à un niveau bas et stable au
fil du temps on peut se demander s'il
faudrait que le mandat soit un peu plus
large je pense à l'emploi quand même
perdu 100 000 emplois au Canada à temps
plein depuis le mois de mai jusqu'à
septembre je pense à toutes les familles
qui vont en ce moment leur taux
hypothécaire monter rapidement s'ils ont
un taux variable il y a des gens qui ont
des difficultés financières il y a de
plus en plus de gens qui pourraient
avoir des difficultés financières est-ce
que vous devriez vous préoccuper de cela
davantage
on essaye de balancer les risques on
veut pas trop augmenter les taux
d'intérêt et trop trop ralentir
l'économie mais au même temps on veut
pas faire on va pas faire moins qu'il y
a besoin qu'est-ce que c'est clair c'est
que l'inflation ici au Canada ça va pas
juste disparaître sans action
et si on fait pas assez
les Canadiens vont souffrir de
l'incorpion encore plus donc oui il y a
les risques à les deux côtés mais comme
vous venez de mentionner notre mandat
est clair c'est pas facile de restaurer
la stabilité des prix mais
après une période de ralentissement
croissance va revenir et on va avoir la
stabilité des prix mais est-ce que la
situation quand même exceptionnelle que
nous vivons présentement devrait nous
amener
à réfléchir de nouveau au mandat de la
Banque du Canada pour avoir un mandat
dual c'est-à-dire de s'occuper de la
création d'emplois également comme le
suggère la sénatrice Diane Bellemare ou
le chef d'une [ __ ]
juste en décembre passé nous avons eu
une une grande période de réflexion et
nous avons parlé au plusieurs Canadiens
nous avons fait de recherche et à
descendre passer nous avons renouvelé
notre mandat avec le gouvernement du
Canada et c'est clair que le mandat
c'est stimulité des prix et qu'est-ce
qu'on nous avons entendu des Canadiens
et c'était pendant période où
l'inflation était très bas c'était même
un pour cent qu’est-ce que nous avons
encore entendu des Canadiens que il
n'aime pas l'inflation l'inflation ils
sont inquiète avec l'inflation c'est
plus difficile de payer
tout ce qu'ils ont besoin donc
je pense que nous avons eu cette période
de réflexion et
avec le gouvernement du Canada nous
avons pris une décision je pense que les
Canadiens n'aiment pas non plus les
hausses de taux d'intérêt n'est-ce pas
et il y a des Canadiens qui n'aiment pas
perdre leur emploi il y a quand même il
y a quand même plusieurs effets à la
politique que vous menez présentement
je veux pas dire que ce sera facile je
comprends que
plusieurs des Canadiens sont endettés et
les augmentations des taux d'intérêt
vont mettre plus de stress sur
c'est quelque chose qu'on suive de près
mais comme j'ai mentionné
il y a pas manières facile de restaurer
la stabilité des prix et qu'est-ce qu'on
entend maintenant des Canadiens c'est
que le prix de nourriture de Blizzard
les prix de louer
presque tous les besoins des Canadiens
les prix sont à la hausse mais
d'ailleurs sur les aliments monsieur
maclem aidez-nous à comprendre on est à
11% d'inflation sur les aliments ce qui
est beaucoup plus élevé que le taux
d'inflation en soi est-ce que ça vous
préoccupe parce que pas un problème là
dans la hausse des prix des aliments
vous avez tout à fait raison les prix
des aliments ont beaucoup augmenté et ça
affecte sur tous les Canadiens à faible
revenu
dont oui on se préoccupe qu'est-ce qu'on
voit avec ses prix c'est que les prix
des produits d'agriculture ont beaucoup
augmenté et la guerre l'attaque russe de
l'Ukraine à encore augmenté ses prix de
plus le prix de transport a augmenté
et maintenant on voit que les prix
d'agriculture de Cramant ça diminuer le
prix des transports grands diminuer et
on anti si on veut voir que c'est cela
est reflété dans les prix pour les
consommateurs et que les épiceries ne
sont pas en train de profiter de la
situation pour augmenter plus fortement
les prix où est le bureau de concurrence
a bien juste lancer une enquête et je
pense que les questions qu'ils ont posé
sont très bons ok en terminant monsieur
maclem comment vous réagissez aux
critiques les banques centrales font
face à toutes sortes de critiques mais
vous vous faites face à des critiques
également qui soit politiques ou
d'ailleurs il y a des gens qui disent
que vous avez failli même à votre tâche
est-ce que votre crédibilité est entaché
par votre gestion de la situation
c'est clair que nous sommes en période
difficile l'inflation est trop haut
l'économie commence à ralentir nous
avons fortement hausser les taux
d'intérêt donc c'est en période
difficile et donc les Canadiens ont
beaucoup de questions pour nous
élus ont beaucoup de questions pour nous
c'est c'est facile à comprendre et on
nous sommes bienvenus au des
commentaires des questions dans les
semaines qui viennent je vais parler au
parlementarien
au Sénat ou chambre commune et
je suis je suis content de leur parler
c'est important c'est une aspect de
notre comptabilité au Canadien
je veux je veux finalement souligner que
il y a une raison pour pendant ces
banques centrales et l'indépendance est
plus important quand c'est une situation
difficile quand même
monsieur maclem c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir pour notre public à zone
économique merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir merci beaucoup à vous pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]